I'm Stanley but you can call me Santa
Lee today I have a very special present
for you from Santa and don't you miss it
egg Celsius
legend tells us one thing history
another but every now and then we find
something that belongs to both you just
don't want to give up doing this all day
[Music]
there are men laying down their lives I
got no right to do any less than that
they're already big men fighting maybe
what we need now it's a little guy bit
becomes worse good becomes great
[Music]
this is value rituals
I shouldn't be like unless it was
fairies
I was shown my legacy I just finally
know what I have to do
[Music]
you become part of a bigger universe you
just don't know it yet
banner thought gamma radiation might
hold the key to unlocking Erskine's
original formula oh you have betrayed
the Express command of your king through
your arrogance and stupidity
I am a worthy son I might be true heir
to the throne these people are innocent
taking their lives will gain you nothing
to take mine and end this
I am Loki and I am burdened with
glorious purpose
we can't protect the Earth you can be
damn well sure we'll avenge it
bah blah blah what the hell does that
have to do with anything
and we'll destroy Xandar and he moves
any price Wow were the guardians of the
galaxy
remember hostile alien army came
charging through a hole in space with
the Avengers that up there that's a game
how are you guys planning on beating
that together
I've missed so much time and want to be
a part of her life what do I do this is
your chance to earn that look in your
daughter's eyes to become the hero that
she already thinks you are
which I saves many people as we can
sometimes that doesn't mean everybody
when you'd be put the check we may not
be perfect but the safest hands are
still our own
[Music]
what do we do we fight
I came here to heal my hands not to
fight in some mystical war your
intellect has taken you far in life but
it will take you no further
so it's saving the galaxy again I guess
oh well any of you do is yell at each
other we're not friends you're right our
family
we get into a situation what happens
then
they'll come back
eat them too
you will have your war hey everybody
happy holidays from Stan the man who
wants to fly to Japan now so that they
can watch infinity war a couple days
early so because of the lead up there
drop in these trailers so I'll explain
what's going on if you are finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything because it's the
holidays and because January is when
everything is getting started they're
gonna be dropping a whole bunch of
footage for everything really soon and
there is new giveaway stuff at the end
of the video too right now they're
shutting down Avengers 4 they're still
actors that have scenes to film just
because there's so many characters in
that movie but like yesterday I posted
that Scarlet Witch vision video they
just wrapped on the film that'll keep
happening with the actors but because
it's the holidays in their heart out is
January so they can start promoting
Black Panther and infinity war naturally
they start posting these things all over
the world so they could get people ready
because we're at the point now where
there's almost 20 Marvel films they're
just gonna be a lot of people that
haven't seen all the films so naturally
they want people to be caught up when
you get to infinity war and when they
were getting ready to start writing
infinity war the writers were really
open about the fact that that yeah we're
not gonna hold people's hands a lot when
it comes to the story if you don't know
every single thing that's happened to
these characters so far by the time the
film starts the film itself won't
explain a lot of that there'll be a
couple throwaway lines about stuff
that's happened in the past obviously
Civil War aka Avengers 2.5 was the last
time those characters were together so
there'll be some references to that like
Tony whips out the little cap phone that
he sent him at the end of that movie
calm hey dude [ __ ] is going down we have
purple man in the sky rally the team
chances are all of you watching this
video have seen all the Marvel movies
multiple times so you probably don't
need an explainer of what happened
during phase 1 phase 2 in what's going
on now during phase 3 but if there are
any special videos that you guys want me
to do for the older movies they just let
me know usually what happens is is
there's a moment in the infinity war
trailer or we see them filming something
behind the scenes like Avengers 4 where
they're wearing old costumes and it
becomes an easter egg for a really old
film that's what they'll do with the
future films is they'll make a lot of
jokes and offhanded remarks about things
that happened a long time ago
like during the trailer Coulson makes
that comment about gamma radiation but
we haven't watched The Incredible Hulk
film and so long we just met Mark
Ruffalo during the Avengers movie and
that was that they just assumed you
understood his origin story but with the
exception of the brand-new characters
like Captain Marvel or anybody in the
new cosmic films that they're getting
ready for like if we get Silver Surfer
obviously they'll have to explain his
origin story when Adam warlock comes
along during guardians 3 or whatever
movie after that they'll explain his
cocoon situation how he just stated in
that and how he's supposed to be this
perfect being but then by the time we
get to Avengers phase 6 or phase 7 if
they have Adam warlock in one of those
movies they're not gonna re explain his
origin story so it's the same thing with
all the characters you've seen so far
like they're assuming that you watch
spider-man homecoming so you don't
necessarily need a new explainer for
where this shiny new stark tech suit
came from but if you do have any special
requests for really old Marvel videos
just let me know in the comments below
most of January is gonna be focused on
Black Panther infinity war and they'll
probably start dropping some Deadpool
footage too so what I'll do because
infinity war is such a big deal is the
giveaway for Marvel videos now will be
the Infinity Gauntlet replicas all you
have to do to enter just be a subscriber
or leave a Marvel related comment on the
video and I'll just remind people when I
post Marvel videos maybe I'll do this
for Deadpool too but I order these
online for people that are always
confused about why I seem to have so
many flash rings it's all from online
it's very simple online retailers
congratulations to the winner from my
last video John Barr shat please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for brand new
Deadpool and click here for my new
infinity war infinity gems video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]